live is life da sind wir wieder und wir
begrüssen jetzt ganz herzlich in münchen
live zugeschaltet karl heinz rummenigge
schönen guten morgen herr um weniger
guten morgen herr brüderle war ja schön
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben und
wir wollen gleich einsteigen erzählen
sie uns wie fühlt sich das leben ohne fc
bayern so ganz formal an ist ja zwei
monate her dass sie ein paar monate
früher als ursprünglich geplant als
vorstandsvorsitzender aufgehört haben
wir haben sie die zeit genutzt was haben
sie zuletzt gemacht
ja es war habe ich einen sehr
ausgedehnten urlaub gemacht muss ich
sagen wir einmal ein schönes haus auf
sylt da ist die ganze familie
mitgefahren und einfach um mal runter zu
kühlen um einfach das kapitel bayern
münchen dann auch zu beenden und denke
das war die richtige entscheidung war
ein schöner sommer dort muss ich sagen
auf sylt mit schönem wetter stimmung und
wir waren alle happy wie war das dann zb
mit dem supercup-spiel gegen die dort
mode hat sich das im fernsehen angeguckt
oder gönnt man sich jetzt tatsächlich
auch mal so ein dienstagabend in ganz
anderem ambiente
habe ich mir angeschaut weil er ein sehr
gutes spiel find ich bei münchen hat
absolut verdient gewonnen und ist ich
weiß bin ich zum wiederholten male haben
sie diesen supercup gewonnen das war
interessant ist natürlich etwas weniger
spannung wenn man nicht mehr total in
der verantwortung steht auf der anderen
seite kann man fußball dann auch mal ich
sage mal ein bisschen neu bewerten ganz
einfach und das spiel fand ich erst mal
von der qualität her gut und es hat den
verdienten sieger bayern münchen am ende
des tages auch gehabt das werden wir
nachher noch vertiefen herumliege sie
waren gestern jetzt das erste mal wieder
im stadion beim heimsieg gegen den 1 fc
köln sicherlich auch weil dort gerd
müller gedacht wurde der vor einer woche
verstorben ist teilen sie mit uns noch
mal ihre gedanken an den großartigen
bomber der nation
ja ich fand es erst mal eine schöne
geste vom fc bayern dass man diese
gedenkfeier gestern gemacht hat uli
hoeneß und herbert hainer haben
wunderbare reden vor dem spiel gehalten
und es kam dann viele alte weggefährten
von ihm vor dem spiel zusammen und wir
haben dann natürlich viel über geld
gesprochen
wie es früher war und ich glaube ja ich
glaube fünf jahre mit ihm zusammen
spielen dürfen und er war natürlich ein
besonderer spieler aber auch ein
besonderer mensch meine der spieler gerd
müller den haben alle gesehen welche und
wie viele tore geschossen hat und
welcher qualität muss man ja auch sagen
aber er war auch ein besonderer mensch
aber ein ganz angenehmer mensch ich kann
mich noch erinnern mein erstes training
an der säbener straße
1974 war 18 jahre blutjung aus lippstadt
am tag vorher angereist und dann bin ich
in die kabine und anstand gerd müller
auf mal vor mir und dann hab ich gesagt
guten morgen herr müller mein name ist
khan zur genüge ich darf geht es mit
ihnen hier trainieren dann hat er mich
angehört wie sagt hey boss ich bin
erklärt und wir spinnen einer mannschaft
von beatle boots mich in der zukunft als
er war ein ganz
prima prima kollege muss ich sagen und
man hat mit ihm wirklich einen tollen
menschen also spieler verloren wir uns
einfach herum legen wenn sie als
ehemaliger weltklasse stürmer uns die
nicht in den genuss gekommen und auf dem
niveau fußball spielen zu können diese
diese qualität von gerd müller wie
würden sie die zusammenfassen was haben
sie als mannschaftskamerad und
stürmerkollege am meisten bewundert wenn
sie ihn auf dem platz erlebt haben
wenn erstmal er hat einen unglaublichen
bildern auch im training er konnte nicht
verlieren und wir haben manchmal zwei
stunden trainingseinheiten gab nur wegen
gerd müller bis dann das spiel zum
schluss wir haben immer zum zum ende
jedes trainings ein spielchen gemacht
und wenn gerd müller nicht gewonnen
hatte wurde das training nicht
abgebrochen und er war in der beziehung
unglaublich und was ihn natürlich
besonders ausgebreitet hat war der
strafraum er war ja kein stürmer der 50
meter sprints abgeschlossen hat dann mit
einem traumschuss in den winkel sondern
eher ein strafraum er kam
links rechts links rechts um energie 20
zentimeter zwischen sich und dem
verteidiger hatte dabei der verteidiger
verloren und er hat nie geknallt er
hatte irgendwie eine reaktionsfähigkeit
die ich bei einem stürmer noch nie
gesehen hat er hat nur geschoben und er
dann so geschrieben dass der torwart
auch eine chance hatte er war biete ich
habe immer gesagt das phantom der oper
des strafraums
wunderbar herum
jetzt aus dieser zeit und dem gedenken
an gerd müller ins hier und jetzt
wiederholen masse reift ja dazu da hier
natürlich bei uns mit im studio ist sie
beide kennen sich auch gut und lange und
weil sie gerade gerd müller so
beschrieben haben dass ihnen der geringe
raum reichte um seine tore zu erzielen
wir haben gerade mit über holland
diskutiert dass genau das etwas ist wenn
man mal einfach so ein vergleich über
die generation zieht was haaland gerade
fehlt und was dem dortmunder spiel
offenbar probleme macht das saarland ein
fachraum braucht um zu funktionieren
herum nie gesehen sie das auch als ein
problem der dortmunder offensive aktuell
ja meine was mir bei dem dortmunder
spiel auffällt ist dass man eigentlich
sofort wenn in der abwehr schon bei
dortmund ball erobert wird dass man
eigentlich dann sofort versucht auch das
mittelfeld zu überspielen umland ins
spiel zu bringen um in den lauf zu
bringen ist natürlich sehr schneller als
körperlich unglaublich stark ich weiß
nur nicht manchmal auch im taktischen
und technischen spiel von dort man
gerecht wird weil man überspielt
eigentlich komplett damit das mittelfeld
dass der angriff dann eigentlich
aufbauen sollte und
es fällt auch dann natürlich auch gegen
bayern oder auch am samstag gegen
freiburg aus dem spiel genommen wird
dann tut sich dortmund schwert dann in
die ergebnisse zu erzählen die man
erzählen möchte herr reif wie sehen sie
es ist das auch ein thema das das
mittelfeld gar nicht so zur geltung
kommt wenn immer schnell der lange ball
gesucht wird nach der ball wird ja nicht
nur nach vorne gespielt sondern richtung
holland es ist alles kahl anteil an
thailand erstens ist das zu verteidigen
wenn du dich entsprechend positioniert
und b wirst du immer den platz haben
müssen zum umschalten wenn andere
mannschaften sagen ihr werdet gegen und
sicht umschalten sondern wir werden
immer so viel wie heißt das wort rest
verteidigung haben dass der heirat nicht
ins laufen kommt dann brauchst du
mittelfeld dann musst du andere lösungen
finden und im moment wo sich genau wie
halle sehe ich ja an der lösung nicht
weder von den figuren noch von der art
fußball zu spielen es ist ein sehr
berechenbarer fußball allerdings wenn er
funktioniert wieder sehen also näher als
50 meter loslaufen kommt das haben wir
am sich zu verteidigen frankfurt gesehen
ja da war ein großartiger tag noch zwei
tore selber gemacht breit vorbereitet
und dann ist ja im prinzip auch im
alleingang der matchwinner herr
rummenigge sie waren gestern im stadion
und haben auch erlebt wie die zuschauer
mit sahne umgegangen sind hat ihnen da
auch als ehemaliger spieler das herz
geblutet als sie mitbekommen haben dass
sich da doch mehrere fans auf ein
bisschen eingeschossen haben und
ausgepfiffen haben und dann sogar der
jubel als bekannt wurde dass nagelsmann
ihn auswechselte droht er da fertig
gemacht zu werden
ja ich meine erstmals mir nicht gefallen
muss ich sagen ich habe schon ein
bisschen mitleid mit ihm gehabt er ist
man hat den eindruck er bemüht sich
jetzt er hat aber kein selbstvertrauen
und man darf natürlich nicht vergessen
er hat keine gute letzte saison gespielt
er hat keine gute europameisterschaft
gespielt und wenn man das zusammen
rechnet dann kommt natürlich irgendwann
bei der ablöse und auch was an gehalt
natürlich irgendwo die kritik der fans
langsam hoch ich habe gestern während im
spiel an das jahr 2012 erinnert da gab
es dieses berühmte finale darum in
münchen mit dem sie zeigen todtraurigen
arjen robben hat ein elfmeter
verschossen in der verlängerung er hatte
vorher in dem spiel gegen borussia
dortmund schon einen elfmeter
verschossen und auch mal waren die fans
ihm gegenüber wahnsinnig kritisch und
hagen war damals so weit dass er fast
und um die freigabe gebeten hätte den fc
bayern zu verlassen und wir haben dann
gesagt nein das machen wir nicht er ist
ein wichtiger spieler des fc bayern wir
müssen ihnen ganz einfach die zu
unterstützen und das haben wir getan und
war damals trainer der hat natürlich mit
ihm
hat ihn wieder aufgebaut hatten die
aufgebaut asien war extrem ehrgeizig hat
trainiert wie nie zuvor und das ergebnis
bekannt ein jahr später gegen dortmund
war er der matchwinner mit dem 2 1 und
ich glaube es wäre gut
die sich jetzt in den arien als vorbild
nimmt wie der damals auch wieder in die
spur zurückgekommen ist er ist ein
spieler mit hohem talent schnell er hat
ein gutes dribbling gute technik guten
schuss er hat dem prinzip alles um 1 1
fc bayern spieler zu werden natürlich
ist man in münchen ein bisschen auch
verwöhnt man hat ihn offen und ribéry
die zwei besten außenspieler der welt
über zehn jahre gesehen und daran werden
natürlich alle gemessen und ich kann ihm
nur empfehlen ich habe das ja schon mal
ich war im letzten dezember gesagt er
muss sich fordern und er muss gefördert
werden beides juliana rieckmann denke
ich wird ihn fördern aber er muss ich
auch selber fordern um ganz einfach
dieses niveau dass er drin hat das in
der liebe glücklicherweise mit dem die
wege gegeben hat dann eben auf dem platz
zu zeigen was glauben sie wie geht
julian nagelsmann jetzt mit ihm um dann
ist ja die frage bringe ich ihnen jetzt
erst recht um ihm eine unterstützung zu
signalisieren und den fans auch zu
zeigen ich glaube an diesen spieler oder
entscheidet er auch das muss man ja
sagen rein leistungsmäßig da macht für
uns im studio hier auch musealer derzeit
einen besseren eindruck wie schätzen sie
nagelsmann da ein
na gut der junge kam gestern sein erster
aktion war sofort das dribbling das dann
zum 1 0 geführt hat dass er glänzend
vorbereitet hat ein trainer hat einen
schmalen grat auf der einen seite muss
er versuchen die spieler in die spur zu
bringen damit sie ganz einfach nach 100
prozent ihrer leistungsfähigkeit kommt
auf der anderen seite muss ein trainer
hilft unter vier spiele gewonnen werden
und ich möchte daran erinnern edwin
ausgewechselt am stand von 0 0 bayern
hat ein relativ zügig 20 gehört dann gab
es noch mal die zwei gegentore aber
eigentlich hätte man trotzdem das gefühl
bayern wird gewinnen und am ende
glücklicher weise als zum 3 2 sieg dann
ja auch gereicht das ist ein schmaler
grat aber er muss versuchen trotzdem den
lido in die bank zurück zu bringen dazu
hat bayern münchen zu viel geld in diese
spieler auch entwickelt und auch zu viel
kraft und dementsprechend glaube ich
wird mir das auch versuchen dass er ihn
zurück bringt also auch für den fall
dass ein verein jetzt doch an bayern ran
tritt und sagt wir würden sehr gerne
nehmen sie würden hoffen dass er nicht
verkauft wird sondern dass er versucht
sich durchzubeißen ich glaube der kader
von bayern münchen liegt auch nicht her
dass man grundsätzlich spieler abgibt
nicht meine ist es gibt grund ja auch
ein beschluss des aufsichtsrats man
eigentlich nur spieler dann verpflichtet
man vorher auch spieler abgegeben werden
und
in der preisklasse von von leroy da gibt
es nicht so viele klubs die überhaupt in
der lage sind damit zu bieten und man
muss versuchen den spieler ziehen in die
bahn zu bringen das würde ich empfehlen
und ich glaube das zu wäre auch das
beste und wie gesagt dann nur
wiederholen arjen robben ist ein tolles
beispiel für lehrer dass ein spieler am
ende des tages auch als touchscreen kann
wenn wir über transfers reden was er
reif und ich haben vorhin schon mal ein
bisschen über sie gesprochen wir beide
das gefühl den gönnt sich bayern in
jedem fall auch wenn es diesen
aufsichtsratsbeschluss gibt denen sie
gerade angesprochen haben das erst
verkauft werden muss sind sie
zuversichtlich dass pullis oder süle
falls man den überhaupt noch verkaufen
will dass so ein verkauf noch gelingt
oder sehen sie gerade er den trend alle
bleiben und sabitzer kommt und ob um
nagelsmann zumindest ein zuckerl noch zu
geben
nein ich glaube dass sich gestern in dem
fall an den aufsichtsratsbeschluss
halten muss das ist ja wie gesagt das
höchste gremium im verein und die gegen
die vorgaben und herbert hainer hat er
bekanntgegeben dass die krone auch ein
finanzieller schaden von 150 millionen
eben entstanden ist und sap ist ein
guter spieler aber ich finde wohl
isoliert mir ein bisschen manchmal zu
sehr unterschätzt auch das war ein guter
spieler wenn ich daran erinnern darf in
der zeit insbesondere als jupp heynckes
das zweite mal trainer war daher fehlt
wohl geschossen dazu ein brauchbarer
spieler leider hat sich dann schwer
verletzte am knie musste operiert werden
aber ich sehe ihn nicht so schlecht wie
er manchmal in den medien oder auch
sonst wie da bekommt deutlich so ist ein
brauchbarer spieler für bayern münchen
gut warten wir ab was an der stelle
passiert und reden wir ein bisschen über
den internationalen fußball herr reif
ronaldo hat gestern darum gebeten erst
mal nicht zu spielen
gegen udine weil ja möglicherweise sich
ja noch ein transfer gibt wo sind wir
jetzt die spieler dürfen selber sich
aussuchen ob sie spielen ob sie nicht
spielen
ronaldo ist schon eine besondere spezies
er ich frage mich nur wo wohin also was
manchester united oder was war da mal
war
ronaldo mit all seinen qualitäten
verändert ja sofort auch der kabine und
er ist keine 25 mehr und um ihn herum
baust du dann die zukunft auf sondern
also deswegen ich weiß nicht warum er
darum gebeten hat er hat kürzlich in
einem interview ziemlich klar gesagt ist
es nervt ihn wie mit ihm herum
spekuliert wird aber wenn er natürlich
gestern wirklich nicht spielen wollte
von anfang an tag befördert er ja und
befeuerte er die spekulationen
das hilft weder juventus die letztes
jahr bin ich nicht irre nicht wirklich
meister geworden sind und das ist
juventus das ist geradezu
gotteslästerung genitalien und
gestern spielen die in udine 22 und
nachdem er reinkommt die am 2 0 geführt
also dass ich möchte im moment nicht in
der haut der verantwortliche bei
juventus stecken weil daran läge sie
können sich ein ziel kennen die bosse
europas alle sehr sehr gut die anja ließ
die bei juve unterwegs sind was glauben
sie wo landet ronaldo jetzt in den
nächsten zehn tagen
naja das größte problem ist erst mal wer
kann überhaupt sein gehalt stimmen in
diesen zeiten ja er wird etwa 35
millionen netto verdient das sind 70
foto
normaler rechnung und der in europa ist
er wohl in der lage vielleicht paris
vielleicht noch der eine oder andere
englische klub aber die frage ist auch
will man einen mittlerweile 35 jetzt
sechs spieler in dem alter mit einem
solchen gehalt ausstatten bald das hat
ja auch gleichzeitig eine rückkopplung
in die kabine die spieler wissen schon
was dein nachbar verdient und wenn einer
dann kommt der 70 millionen verdient
dann wollen die anderen automatisch
natürlich mehr verdienen weil sie sagen
ich bin hier der große nachwuchsstar und
möchte daneben zumindest an den 70
millionen auch ein bisschen auch wenn es
weniger ist naschen und wir haben da
eine entwicklung die es grundsätzlich
ungesund kann nur noch mal betonen die
uefa ist hier gefragt ganz einfach etwas
zu tun damit die kosten reduziert werden
im moment werden die kosten ja nochmal
aufgebläht im speziellen gehalts bereich
oder auch bei den beratern und wenn da
nicht wenn da nicht jetzt vernünftige
regularien getroffen werden in den
nächsten monaten
da muss ich klar und deutlich sagen geht
der fußball schweren schweren
finanziellen zeiten
rummenigge wir haben ja noch leichter
schnappatmung in anbetracht der 35
millionen euro netto und ich sie gerade
noch mal als gehalts schild bei ronaldo
daran geklebt haben unglaublich in
welchen dimensionen wir uns da
mittlerweile bewegen wie das früher eine
aufregung war wenn ein spieler eine
million gekostet hat oder sie damals
zehn millionen mark 1984 als transfer
von bayern zu inter mailand unglaubliche
entwicklung wir haben am donnerstag die
champions-league-auslosung das passt
dazu gibt natürlich ein reifes live
spezial am donnerstag 18 uhr live
hierbei bild live man hat gerade den
eindruck dass chelsea
paris mancity ja dass die gerade einfach
alle gesetze aushebeln
ist das wirklich dieses jahr vielleicht
zum ersten mal etwas ungleicher
wettbewerb zuerst die frage an sie herr
rummenigge
naja ich meine man es fällt natürlich
auf das im prinzip die engländer haben
einen wettbewerbsvorteil erstmal sie
klingt dreimal höheres tv geld als wir
hier in deutschland dazu die ganzen
großen klubs zum beispiel chelsea
abramowitsch
manchester city abu dhabi oder arizona
wird von katar
sind die besitzer die ernte kirchentag
wettbewerbsvorteile geld ist in hülle
und fülle vorhanden und ich kann ihn
auch hin ich sage mal wir sind da noch
mittendrin in kona wir wissen eigentlich
wie das ausgeht alle waren wir der
meinung im letzten sommer oder im
letzten juni corona in der nächsten
saison wird es nicht mehr geben wir
werden wieder volle stadien haben jetzt
dann war ich im stadion 20.000 zuschauer
stimmung war wieder was da muss man
sagen aber es fehlen immer noch 55.000
zuschauer um eben ausverkauftes haus zu
melden und wir müssen hier in
deutschland da anders rechnen und ich
hatte ein langes gespräch vor kurzem mit
aki watzke wir machen uns da große sorge
langsam wenn ihm gesagt nicht regularien
gefunden werden
bundesliga am ende des seils große
leidtragende sein wird herr reif wie
sehen sie es ist die bundesliga auf
sicht nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig
international wenn die entwicklung die
wir aktuell beobachten anhält
kann sagt er macht sich sorgen mit aki
watzke und das große ganze sie werden
sich natürlich auch fragen müssen wo
positionieren wir uns also willst
international mitspielen und die bayern
haben ja gezeigt es geht aber geht das
auf dauer wenn die anderen dermaßen
weiter geld um sich werfen wo wo
entscheidest du wohin entscheidest du
dich dann sagt das machen wir nicht mit
dann wirst du glaube ich denn geld
schießt sehr wohl tore wenn es gut
ausgegeben da nicht herausfinden wird
und dann stehst du da und kannst
irgendwann nicht mehr konkurrieren die
bundesliga gegen gegen gegen die
englische liga zu stellen ist das tut
fast schon weh in der spitze haben die
bayern gut hingekriegt die dog oder war
zumindest
bemüht und zuweilen auch erfolgreich
aber vom von der systematik der calle
und mir fehlt ein bisschen die die
hoffnung also regularien finden welches
höhere nur ein bestimmter teil des
geldes dafür gehälter ausgegeben werden
muss die strafe zahlen ich habe nicht
das gefühl dass sie in abu dhabi und in
katar jetzt in anfangen zu zittern würde
dann wie viel macht das noch mal aus das
ist ja unsere sachen herum einige es
gibt financial fairplay regularien am
ende finden die die wollen doch immer
irgendwelche wege um das zu mb umgehen
und dann doch diese fantasie gehälter zu
zahlen haben sie wirklich den optimismus
dass da ein scharfes schwert gefunden
werden kann um dem einhalt zu gebieten
ich meine ich habe ja gelesen dass es
veränderung geben soll in der gestalt
dass man in der zukunft eben regularien
einführt wie erlauben bis zu 70 prozent
des umsatzes abgegeben bayern münchen
hat in der bitte 700 750 millionen
umgesetzt volk ohne das würde bedeuten
dass beim 500 millionen ausgeben da
dürfte theoretisch auf die periode der
spieler das funktioniert aber nicht ich
habe mit zwei großartigen finanzamt
bayern münchen im vorstand
zusammengearbeitet karl hopfner und jan
andresen und wir haben eine rechnung
aufgemacht sobald wir über 53 prozent
seines umsatzes in gehälter investierst
bist du in den roten zahlen vergisst
geld dementsprechend das kann vielleicht
in paris das kann vielleicht auch in
england funktionieren wenn die besitzer
da eltern nachschießen oder zu schießen
in deutschland bei 50 plus eins ist das
ja auch gar nicht möglich und es keinen
bestand haben dementsprechend ich glaube
wir brauchen eine lösung sage ich mal
nicht nur für england auch nicht nur für
paris verbraucher eine lösung für den
gesamten europäischen fußball weil meine
es betrifft uns in deutschland es
betrifft aber auch andere länder und
andere klubs große klubs im moment die
größten leid zeigen dann kann ich nur
sagen sind die spanier real mit
barcelona das kind member klubs also
klubs die nur von mitgliedern
eben im
gewählt werden und dort gibt es keinen
der einen euro in den verein zu schießt
wenn die irgendein spieler kaufen wollen
und dementsprechend laufen die
wettbewerbsbedingungen wie laufen ganz
einfach im moment in eine richtung die
glaube ich aus der bundesliga groß
besorgen müssen ok herum innige punkt
ist angekommen wir wollen ganz am ende
noch einmal kurz sprechen über jürgen
klopp den hatten wir gestern am
premierentag von bild live zugeschaltet
aus liverpool der muss sich ja gerade
auch ein bisschen auf die zunge beißen
weil liverpool nur 40 millionen
ausgegeben hat ist ja auch viel weniger
als in der vergangenheit er hat sich zu
seiner zukunft geäußert und das hören
wir uns doch einmal kurz an
ich habe ich ja gesagt falls wir nicht
in liverpool bis 2024 dann
sind ja urlaub das heißt hansi flick
urlaub wenn sie bin ich ihre frage
stellen ist praktisch anti kriegs
vertrag müssen bis 225 laufen
in frage geben weil es bei 24 bei mir
gerne anrufen einen wie immer bestens
gelaunter jürgen klopp herum liga
verraten sie einmal wiener waren die
bayern denn wirklich mal dran an einer
verpflichtung
ich glaube wir waren vom timing her
haben wir nicht zusammen ist dass das
ist das problem wir hatten uli hoeneß
insbesondere hatte mal ich glaube als
wir jürgen klinsmann dann damals unter
vertrag genommen haben kontakt mit ihm
ich hatte auch zwischendurch kontakt mit
dem er ist ja mein quasi nachbar auf
sylt und er ist ein toller mensch finde
ich ein toller trainer das hat er ja
auch insbesondere jetzt nochmal in
liverpool unter beweis gestellt was hat
irgendwie vom timing her nie
funktioniert und dementsprechend ist
bayern münchen ist die ehe bei münchen
jürgen klopp hat nie stattgefunden
herr rummenigge wir danken ihnen ganz
herzlich dass sie sich heute die zeit
genommen haben hierbei reifes live der
tv premieren gast zu sein und hoffen
dass er bald wieder auf diesem wege
zusammen kommen ihnen alles alles gute
nach münchen grüßen sie die familie bis
dann
vielen dank und liebe grüße zurück nach
berlin